tenemos este modelo que se llama
explorando la media y la mediana y
veamos que dice nos dice coloca los 10
puntos anaranjados estos son nuestros
puntos anaranjados en la recta numérica
de tal forma que la media aritmética sea
0.8 recuerda que la media aritmética lo
que realmente se refiere es al promedio
digamos que si tenemos 10 puntos
sumaremos cada uno de ellos y después lo
dividiremos entre 10 entonces esta media
aritmética nos dará 0.8 y la mediana
será de 0.5 la mediana lo que nos mide
es realmente el punto entre los dos
números centrales si nosotros tenemos un
número par como en este caso tendremos 5
del lado izquierdo 5 del lado derecho y
justo el promedio entre ambos números
centrales será la mediana o si
tuviésemos un número menor por ejemplo 9
sería el número que se encuentra justo a
la mitad tendríamos 4 a la izquierda 4 a
la derecha y el
la mediana ambos los que nos dan son las
tendencias centrales pero como ustedes
pueden ver nos pueden dar diferentes
números esto debido a que uno nos puede
dar mayor cercanía o un número mucho más
exacto y veremos ejemplos para poderlo
poner claro nos indica también que la
distancia entre las marcas consecutivas
es de 1 empezamos en 0 1 2 3 4 5 y hacia
la izquierda tendremos menos 1 - 2 - 3 -
4 menos 5 en cada una de estas marcas si
yo muevo este número que es el más
grande pueden ver cómo empiezo a jugar
con él se afecta el promedio
pero no la mediana no están viendo esto
porque la mediana sigue siendo el
promedio entre los dos números centrales
por eso nos dicen que muchas veces la
mediana no suele dar un dato más exacto
si yo tengo aquí un número super
disparado no me afectará la mediana me
muestra no será afectada por todo esto
ahora veamos si yo muevo
estos números llegaremos hasta 0.8
vamos en 0.7 0.8 de esta forma tengo ya
el promedio o la media aritmética como
0.8 ahora vamos por la mediana la
mediana a ser el promedio entre estos
dos centrales si estamos en cero y
quieren que nos vayamos hacia el 0.5
pues no veremos estos dos puntos
0.5 tuvimos aquí un pequeño movimiento
lo ven la mediana que ven 0.5 mientras
el promedio quedó en punto 9 así es que
bajaremos uno de estos datos se dan
cuenta cómo puedo mover estos datos sin
que la mediana se mueva el promedio está
teniendo cambios sin embargo la mediana
sigue fija esto es porque tenemos los
puntos centrales fijos ahora ya tenemos
el promedio en punto 8 y tenemos la
mediana en 0.5 cuál de estos nos dará el
dato de la tendencia central mucho más
exacto bueno en este caso no hay mucha
diferencia vemos otro ejercicio para ver
si podemos verlo más claro vamos a
comprobar la respuesta y es correcta una
vez más ahora nos están pidiendo que el
coloquemos para que la media aritmética
sea 2.7 y la mediana sea 1 igual tenemos
10 puntos por lo tanto la mediana sera
el promedio entre estos dos centrales
vamos a mover la mediana para que sea 1
perfecto tenemos la mediana en 1 y ahora
el promedio o la media aritmética será
2.7 podemos mover entonces estos y vean
cómo se ve afectado el promedio no así
la mediana recuerda que por eso muchas
veces la mediana es un número para
indicarnos mejor la tendencia central
vamos a ver entonces no vemos estos
números que son los que están como muy
destacados
elegimos estos y estos los podemos ir
subiendo
recuerda que tenemos muchos datos
tenemos 10
vamos en 185 22.05
255 2.7
perfecto con esto tenemos entonces la
mediana y el promedio cual nos está
dando un dato más exacto pues podemos
decir que la mediana está mucho más
cercano a la mayoría de los datos que
tenemos si se dan cuenta que tenemos
como unos destacados son unos que salen
de lo normal y con esto podemos decir
que la gran mayoría de la población se
encuentra justo de este lado y la
mediana representa un número mucho más
certero
vamos a comprobar esta respuesta y es
correcta nos salió una carita feliz que
nos da aquí mostrar pistas ustedes
pueden dar clic en este botón y poco a
poco nos dará mayor información por
ejemplo nos indica el número de enmedio
es la mediana esto ya lo habíamos y
siempre nos dará el mismo número de
datos hacia la derecha que el mismo
número de datos hacia la izquierda
tenemos 5 del lado derecho 5 del lado
izquierdo veamos más información o nos
puede mostrar un ejemplo está nuestra
respuesta y ya está correcta nos está
mostrando aquí un ejemplo
nos dice que el promedio y la mediana
será igual a 1 y este sería el tipo d
respuesta que tendría podemos incluso
tener mucha más información
respecto tanto al promedio como a la
mediana
sin embargo esto no va a cambiar nuestra
respuesta es simplemente información en
caso de que requieras pistas para
solucionar de una mejor manera tu
ejercicio y finalmente nos está dando un
ejemplo de cómo pudimos haber puesto 2.7
con mediana 1 que es exactamente el
ejercicio que habíamos hecho
y vaya justo justo resulta distinto a lo
que habíamos hecho una distribución
distinta sin embargo sigue siendo
correcta la distribución fue distinta si
te fijas la mediana sigue siendo el
punto medio entre estos dos y en este
caso la mediana nos da una mejor
respuesta dado que están agrupados todos
los datos hacia este lado hacia menos
entre menos 2 y 2 se puede decir y estos
son datos que salen como de la tendencia
general que se tiene por eso la mediana
no representa en este caso un número
mucho más certero para dar la tendencia
central